What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
Today we will be finding out how much
more difficult it is playing with our left hands
instead of our right hands
Ok, with the right hand
Around the net and through the tape roll.
I think it went through!
Seven tries?
Or eight
Not bad
With the left hand I will get it with nine tries!
I don't think so!
That was close!
Doesn't count
Are you making fun of my technique?
Yes, a bit!
I was sure that was going to be the one!
There!
That's the one!
Look at the balls! You thought it
would be nine tries or something.
The next one is a target shot on a cup
Let's start with the left hand
It feels like I don't have any control at all
It also looks like that!
Alright, it's time for the right hand
I think this should go within 5 shots
That was four!
Yeah, definitely a lot easier with the strong hand
Target shooting
Let's see how well we can do that with
the left hand
Let's see if we can get even 2 in a row!
And don't forget to subscribe
To help us reach 1 million subscribers!
That was okay!
It's not as impressive as our right hand
playing
But it's something!
5 behind the back shots in a row
This should be easy!
But I don't think it will be that easy with the left hand.
You missed the ball!
Try that one!
What was I supposed to do?
Alright, this is the one!
17th try.
So we have to go around these cups
And land it inside this one.
First try!
Not a bad one.
A bit too short
So close!
That's the one, I'm pretty sure about it!
That was maybe 15
I'm pretty happy about it
I think the left hand is gonna be very
difficult
I have never tried this with my left hand
But I think it is going to be near 100 attempts.
Let's see
There is not enough spin
I almost want to give up right now
30 minutes later
That's finally the...!
What a shame.
I have to stretch my wrist a bit
It's too painful
No wonder after 1 hour of trying this!
Yeah, that's the one!
No, it's not enough spin.
This is the one!
It has to go in!
YES!
It probably took like 600 tries or something!
It felt like you would really have to learn again all kind of spins and everything
It's so different with the wrong hand
And painful!
I think it's safe to say that our right hand trick shots were a bit better than our left.
Dont forget to subscribe to our channel here
And watch our previous episodes there
Until next time!